There's more to the "Five Nights at Freddy's"
movie than just creepy mechanical monsters
and jumpscares, though there are plenty of
those, too.
Let's dig into what all that mayhem really
meant.
The film's protagonist, Mike Schmidt, suffers
from anxiety that's spurred by a traumatic
incident from his childhood.
When Mike was a kid, his younger brother Garrett
was abducted while they were on a camping trip.
Now, as an adult, he uses his dreams to figure
out who took him, with no success.
Not only does this nightmare cause him to
struggle to keep a job, but it also affects
his relationship with his younger sister Abby,
who he cares for by himself.
Mike's newest job, a seemingly harmless nighttime
security gig at a closed children's party
venue called Freddy Fazbear's Pizza, quickly
becomes unsettling when the animatronics come
to life at night.
At first, they appear friendly as they develop
a strong bond with Abby.
Unfortunately, that's only a ruse so they
can manipulate Mike's desire for answers about Garrett.
The animatronic characters ultimately make
a deal with him for Abby.
Mike regretfully accepts, and the friendly
characters turn violent to please their unseen master.
Mike is nearly killed by his newfound animatronic
foes, but he's rescued by his friend Vanessa,
who discloses everything she knows about Freddy's.
"Have you met them yet?"
"Met…who?"
This includes that her father, William Afton,
is the orchestrator of this nightmare, and
that the animatronics that Mike has been dealing
with have a horrific past of their own.
Decades ago, Afton, the mysterious owner of
Freddy Fazbear's Pizza, brought Freddy and
the other animatronics to life by kidnapping
children and stuffing them into the mechanical mascots.
This caused their souls to be intertwined
with the machinery.
Now, Afton controls them through drawings
that influence their beliefs, and is looking
to add another child, Abby, to his collection.
"They want to make her like them."
Now knowing all this, Mike heads back to Freddy
Fazbear's to stop Freddy.
Mike runs into Afton -- who reveals himself
to be the guy who gave Mike this job under
the name Steve Raglan.
With his own mechanized yellow bunny suit,
Afton senselessly beats Mike.
He's only thwarted by Abby, who uses her own
drawings that show Freddy and the others what
Afton did to them.
She convinces them to betray Afton, just as
the spring traps in his costume cause him
to be locked in it forever.
As the building falls apart, Freddy and his
companions pull Afton away while Mike and
Abby help a severely-injured Vanessa escape.
Some time later, Mike visits Vanessa in the
hospital and shares a family dinner with Abby,
promising that they could see Freddy again
one day.
Meanwhile, one of the ghost children leaves
Afton behind a locked door so that he suffers
the same fate as his victims.
At the start of the film, Mike blames himself
for Garrett's abduction, searching for answers
years after his disappearance.
He even recreates and relives Garrett being
taken through his dreams just to find clues.
His frustrations from his failures also drive
him to be incredibly cold towards Abby.
He cruelly chastises her for having imaginary
friends, seemingly wishing that Garrett was
there instead of her.
That's what makes him so vulnerable to the
ghost children who inhabit Freddy and his cronies.
He nearly loses Abby because of that pain.
Mike instantly regrets his initial decision
to trade Abby for Garrett, and does everything
he can to fix things.
He realizes that Abby is just as important
to him as Garrett was, and sets out to stop
Freddy from turning Abby into an animatronic.
When Mike gets a moment alone with Abby, he
apologizes for how he treated her and dedicates
himself to being a better brother.
Based on the film's ending, Mike seems to
live up to that promise.
He now acts as a better parental figure for
Abby, sharing dinner with her just like their
family used to do.
Mike turns things around for himself and has
the potential for a better relationship with
Abby, no longer trapped by his guilt.
As Mike finds a sort of redemption, Afton
finally gets punished for his horrible crimes.
In the climactic final battle, Afton is slowly
cut down by the spring traps in his animatronic
suit and becomes stuck inside it.
As he bleeds out and the building falls apart,
he's dragged away.
We don't see what happens to him until the
final scene, where Afton is in one of the backrooms.
The ghost children leave him there for dead.
He's still alive, but not going anywhere any
time soon.
"The owner's just not ready to let it go yet."
The ghost children, and the mechanical monsters
they inhabit, are no longer under Afton's control.
Thanks to the picture that Abby draws of Afton
killing the children, the magic bind that
Afton has over Freddy and the other animatronics
is broken.
They're fully able to act on their own, and
it's a key reason why they all turn on Afton in the end.
Now, Freddy and his friends are more powerful
than Afton, leaving him to the same fate they
suffered before they died.
It's hard to say whether Afton will simply
die now or if this could be the start of his
return as a larger-than-life nightmare.
But, at least for now, his reign of terror
has come to an end.
The personal trauma Mike deals with is the
emotional core of "Five Nights at Freddy's."
The film's depiction of how lingering grief
can lead someone to lose themselves is a horror in itself.
Although Mike's erratic behavior and cruel
treatment of Abby make him tough to like at
first, it's hard not to feel something for
him as his trauma becomes clear.
He's so desperate to find any resolution to
what happened to Garrett that it's the only
thing he dreams about.
His hunger for the truth runs so deep that
he uses his sleeping pills to fall into a
deep slumber so that his dreams are more surreal.
His residual anxiety causes him to lash out
at others, including a man he mistakenly thinks
is kidnapping a child.
The film's depiction of Mike's stress is easily
relatable to anyone who struggles to let go
of the past or is haunted by it.
It drives him to put Abby in peril and consumes
him so greatly that it detaches from reality entirely.
It's what makes Mike's growth so impactful,
and there are some great moments, like Mike's
apology to Abby and the realization of his
mistakes, that emphasize him coming out of
his own darkness.
Although "Five Nights at Freddy's" features
five main ghost children who have distinct
connections to Freddy and his machine allies,
there are surely more.
Afton clearly has a pattern of abducting children,
and the fact that he took Garrett so long
ago likely means that he's been doing this
for quite a while.
It's very probable that Afton has put other
children into mech suits over the years, and
some of the other characters seen in the background
could signify past attempts.
In the backroom that characters walk in and
out of throughout the film, there's a dog
character — possibly a reference to the
urban legend of Sparky from the games — seen lying down.
There's also that horrifying-looking husk
that looks suspiciously like Circus Baby that
Abby is nearly put into.
They're broken apart now, but maybe these
once housed the kids Afton took at some point.
The possibility of there being more ghost
children is especially strong considering
that there are a lot more characters from
the games still to make their debut.
Afton's obsession with building these goofy
animatronics and putting kids in them sadly
has a long history, so who knows how many
ghost kids are really out there?
It's safe to say that there are more than
five.
The ambiguity surrounding Garrett's fate makes
it very possible that he's another ghost that
Mike and Abby could meet in the near future.
Although Afton admits to having taken Garrett
when Mike was a kid, he's not exactly clear
about what happened to him.
He says that Garrett is gone, but that could
just mean that he was stuffed into one of
the animatronics.
This mystery has strong potential to keep
Mike and Abby around in the franchise and
give them personal motivations to look for
more of Freddy's companions.
The re-emergence of Garrett as a ghost child
also could help fill in the gaps of what happened
while he was with Afton.
It could lead to more explanation of how Afton
brings these animatronics to life, as well
as who he really is, especially since Afton
is largely absent throughout most of the film.
Garrett could be the key to really understanding
Afton and this weird world where ghosts and
machines combine to create uncanny horrors.
The fates of Freddy and his pals are also
left ambiguous and could have some strong
implications for what's next in their story.
The control that Afton has had over them is
now destroyed, so they're basically free to
do whatever they want.
After they leave Afton to either die or become
merged with his costume, the characters could
leave the place all together and find somewhere
else to call home.
Maybe they go and find Abby to rekindle their
friendship.
Or perhaps their exit from Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza could result in them visiting some of
the other locations from the games.
Longtime "Five Nights at Freddy's" fans know
that as more sequels came out, the series
continually expanded outside of Freddy Fazbear's
Pizza.
Perhaps the next film could be the right time
to bring fans to Freddy's Frights, a horror-centric
attraction that acted as the third game's
setting.
Or, there's potential for the characters to
explore the sister location from the fifth
game, Circus Baby's Entertainment and Rental,
and introduce Circus Baby to the mix.
The options are wide open for what Freddy
and his friends are up to, especially now
that they seem to be fully autonomous.
"There are ghost children possessing giant
robots?
Thanks for the heads up."
There's currently no confirmation of a sequel
to "Five Nights at Freddy's" going into development,
but the chances of it happening are very high.
The film already made its money back before
it even hit theaters, thanks to the sale of
streaming and theatrical distribution rights.
So what could happen in a potential sequel?
The ending of the film doesn't give many hints,
nor does the mid-credits scene, since it's
basically just a fun scare gag with the Balloon
Boy statue.
We can guess, though, that the movies will
probably continue the story of the games,
remixing some of the events and introductions.
It's worth noting that the film doesn't follow
the games beat for beat, and introduces things
that don't appear until later games.
For instance, Springtrap, who is represented
by Afton's costume choice, doesn't appear
until the third game.
This means that other unseen characters and
locations can appear at any point.
A sequel could also weave together plot points
from the other games to create a narrative
cocktail of the franchise's best parts.
So while a "Five Nights at Freddy's" sequel
is almost certainly on the horizon, it won't
exactly be predictable for fans of the games.
When Matthew Lillard, who plays Afton, appeared
on the WeeklyMTG podcast to talk about "Magic
the Gathering," he also revealed some interesting
information about his contract.
"I just got cast in a movie called 'Five Nights
at Freddy's.'
It's a three-picture deal with Universal and
Blumhouse."
Unless Lillard is also planning to appear
in other Universal and Blumhouse projects
as a part of that deal, it can be assumed
that he's going to be a part of a "Five Nights" trilogy.
This news lines up with director Emma Tammi's
desire to see the films be the start of a
franchise she'd like to return to.
Tammi told ScreenRant that there's so much
more for potential sequels to explore, saying,
"Oh, my gosh, well, the lore is massive.
There was no way we were ever going to fit
everything into one film, nor was it the intention.
So the answer is yes, there's so much to potentially
bring into any sequels should we be lucky
enough to make them."
According to those directly involved, fans can have at least some expectation of more Five Nights At Freddy's films
that delve deeper into the lore.